on today's show jamie lee curtis
sigourney weaver ned
campbell sarah michelle geller and me
mark ellis
and while it's true only one of those
names will be appearing on this show the
four others
will be duking it out for sisterhood
survival supremacy
and they know a thing or two about
surviving all four are considered final
girls a term coined for a leading lady
who makes it through a horror thriller
with their life intact
so you'll forgive us it's the occasional
ending of alien 3 or
buffy the vampire slayer season 5 is up
here by and large if you're a movie
villain
or a creature of cinema or even a spider
in their house i don't like your odds
not against these gals who've combined
to conquer the likes of murderous
siblings
clingy aliens undead armies and in a
shocking twist
their own boyfriend what's the matter
sydney you look like you've seen a ghost
rendering a decision on who wins in this
all-time battle is
me the guy who's never been to outer
space or ran over a fisherman
or had his brother tried to stab him
i've never even been called on the phone
and been asked the scary movie trivia
and i think i'd do well with that one
come on ghost face
step up you got my number do you wanna
die
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three
enemies and then i'll do a wild card
round that sigourney weaver hopes will
involve
who's slept the farthest above the
covers
carried away in bill murray no we don't
have that it's from ghostbusters i'm
afraid of all it goes but jamie lee
nev sigourney and sarah michelle they
say bring it on
so i say let's get it on hold on round
one
box office nothing makes for a night out
at the movies quite like a good scary
flick
so for all purposes of this and all
rounds we're going to keep each
competitor's film resume
to movies that exist somewhere in the
horror thriller sci-fi range
sorry cruel intentions i tried to
squeeze you in true eyes
i love you but no heartbreakers well
jennifer love hewitt was and i know what
you did last summer
so they're i'm being told to move along
so
are you gonna kill me or are we just
making small talk
you the dear viewer whose taxes don't in
any way pay my salary
maybe thinking that this round is a bit
unfair for sarah michelle geller as she
was preoccupied making eight great
seasons of buffy the vampire slayer on
tv
while her counterparts were making hit
movies but to that i'd simply say
scooby dooby doo
scooby-doo counts as a horror sci-fi
movie
whether it's a real ghoul or you're just
freaked out by a talking dog
those flicks hauled in a combined 370
million dollars at the box office
beefing up sarah's overall
total box office to over 900 million
dollars
for a perfect average of 136 million
one of the movies helping her out is
scream 2 which also stars
nev campbell she had a great 1996
as both the craft and scream the
original one
were released and since then her
combined movies have gone on to
accumulate
695 million dollars total for a per film
average of 139 million
her most boffo box office has been
thanks to her starring role
as sydney prescott in the scream
franchise to date the four movies have
totaled 644 million bucks
yes it's a great ensemble cast but
without nev being the glue that keeps
woods burrowed together
we ain't getting a series of films that
rival the popularity
of the previous movies they give a wink
and nod to we're starting to sound like
some wes carpenter flickers
sorry tatum i think you might mean john
carpenter the fella who directed jamie
lee curtis in her first
starring role opposite looming shape
michael myers
still one of the most profitable movies
of all time 1978's halloween
made 188 million dollars off a
production budget that was less than
what it cost
one x-men film to feed hugh jackman all
that wolverine protein
and while jamie didn't appear in every
halloween sequel she made the ones in
which she did return
count as in counting moolah her
halloween films have totaled 587 million
dollars
overall but those aren't her only
scarce-centric titles
jamie lee curtis also carried movies
like prom night the fog
and terror train to financial success
although her average box office per film
is the lowest of our four stars at 76
million per movie
again apologies to her and billy ray
valentine but i can't toss trading
places in here
don't say so now sigourney weaver steps
up to the plate
regarded as a pioneer in the realm of
badass women taking charge and saving
the day at the talking pictures
and for good reason remember how
predators struggle
battling aliens yeah they should have
watched more ellen ripley game film her
marquee franchise
alien has grossed a total of 730 million
dollars across her four movies so far
and when we toss in the likes of the
ghostbusters franchise and roles and
thrillers like copy cat and the village
this round is an easy win for dana
barrett but hey even if we stick with
just the alien pictures
her per film average still ranks at the
top of this heap
at 156 million dollars per outing
okay i might have tossed in her cameo
and cabin in the woods too
that elevator scene is bonkers
sigourney wins round number one and
she's up one
to nothing to nothing to nothing
you got some moves on you girl round two
tomato meter slash
audience score okay ladies let's see who
can prevent ellen ripley from going up
two to nothing yes audiences love seeing
a good chest bursting
alien even if it doesn't sing and dance
but does the tomato meter approve of
sigourney weaver's outer space
exploits yep kinda
alien and aliens are all-time sci-fi
stalwarts registering at 98 and 97
respectively but before you go crowing
game over man
the punchline is that her last two
entries alien 3 and alien resurrection
are both rotten and along with the
certified fresh cabin in the woods that
gets her average to
77 percent still considerably above her
competition
but movies like ghostbusters 2 copycat
and especially the rotten
the village at 42 percent anchor her
average down further
what nonsense are you saying nev
campbell is showing up to play
big time in this round as she's the only
other lady with a fresh average for her
thrillers
notching 64 percent her high water marks
are for scream
2 at 82 percent and the original scream
at 79
and while scream 3 did go rotten scream
4 came back to fresh territory
at 60 percent even for completionists
the craft is
so close to french 55 we're one good
spell away
maybe we get a sequel
sarah michelle geller has a rotten
average of her film rolls at 33
the grudge 2 the return both scooby-doo
movies they all punch in at 30
or lower but here comes buffy if we toss
in her seasons of fresh television the
vampire slayer and angel
are at 82 and 88 percent respectively
but it only gets her to treading water
with a 40 average
that's okay she's doing a voice in the
new he-man show so smg
still has the power it's all up to jamie
lee curtis here
and while her per film average is only
54
on the tomato meter what impresses me is
how well she does
outside of her halloween wheelhouse the
fog and road games are fresh alongside
her best halloween hits
and speaking of those spooky movies
jamie lee curtis can boast
four films in the top 10 of all film
catalogs combined
which begs the question what about the
audience score
jamie lee curtis has five of the top ten
in that list
as rotten tomato meter movies like
halloween two
make the leap from 30 percent to a fresh
63
according to the audience why won't he
die so while sigourney weaver certainly
has an argument with her first two alien
movies
and nev campbell is within shouting
distance laurie strode is getting the w
in round number two
which she probably hates because it's
only going to draw more attention to her
and thus get on the radar of michael
myers mike
if you're watching and let's face it
what else did you have in your i
calendar today
don't stab the messenger i met jamie lee
curtis once in a quiznos parking lot
she was very nice oh we're still doing
the show
it's one to one to nothing to nothing do
you know
that i pray every night
that he would escape what the hell do
you do that for
so i can kill him round three enemy
when it comes to the first two rounds
sigourney and jamie lee had a sizable
head start
as their careers kicked into high gear
in the late 70s
nev and sarah michelle didn't emerge as
stars until the 90s
but you know who doesn't care about that
timeline evil
all right i get it you're evil do we
have to chat about it all day as sydney
in the scream franchise
nev campbell had to not only tangle with
a mysterious killer who through the four
films had multiple identities underneath
the classic ghostface mask
that wasn't the only competition she
faced by the time we meet her in high
school
she's already haunted by the tragic
death of her mother and those bratty
kids at her
educational institution didn't exactly
form a safe space to nurture her
recovery
how do you gut someone you take a knife
and you slit them from groin the sternum
there was the constant press hounding as
well
which only intensified once gail
weathers made claims that the man they
found guilty of killing sid's mom
may actually be innocent that alone is
enough to make anyone weary
and when we toss in the fact that her
boyfriend the johnny depp adjacent skeet
ulrich was half of the villainous
gangsters trying to kill her it's pretty
rough for sid
the three sequels further traumatized
sydney as she had to watch a sizeable
chunk of her friends get sliced and
diced
well into chunks if she only had a
mentor that could have lent some
friendly advice as to
how to battle a shape that won't stop
like laurie strode
her sometimes bro michael broke bad
early and by the time we see his first
person perspective in smooth panaglide
he's already descended into a dead-eyed
stone-cold lead-footed monster
and while i'd take ghostface over
michael myers at the nfl combine
the slow lumbering og eventually arrived
at his destination
murder town which if you're hannibal
lecter is the equivalent of flavortown
laurie and sydney both had to tangle
with a specific masked entity
sydney could never sleep because some
other baddie always took up the mantle
laurie couldn't get any shut-eye because
killing michael is tougher than prying a
xenomorph off your face huh
what's that what's a xenomorph ellen
ripley knows the answer
she's seen them attack her pals
threatened her freshly shaved head
hell she's even housed one inside her
womb and the problem with aliens
is that they just keep wanting to make
babies and procreate and
kill anything that doesn't have two
drooly mouths and while i think we can
all consider ellen the ultimate survivor
she ultimately chose to sacrifice
herself rather than allow the company to
harvest what's going on
inside her body so jamie lee and nev had
to endure multiple battles with
human-ish
villains and ellen had to play an away
game in deep space to encounter her
nemesis
it's a tough call between these three
but back on earth
none of them had to deal with the
constant threat of the undead armies
that thrive on centuries of
blood-sucking day-napping power
that job belonged to buffy i don't know
think it's something cool tell him i
said it if you're known as the vampire
slayer
you're probably good at your job but
this isn't a dream gig
like being a pro athlete or an internet
host this was a lifelong task
thrown at sarah michelle geller's
trademark character when she
like sydney was still finding herself in
high school
our expert researcher mark hoffmeyer
noted that she's killed
hundreds of vampires in her day and when
you go off on so many anti-garlic
mongers that hoffmeier loses count
you're doing something right did i get
it
did i get it then buffy pulled an ellen
ripley and sacrificed herself to save
the world at the end of season five
don't worry she came back in season six
and picked up right where she left off
so even though she didn't make it
through scream 2 or the grudge 2
or i know what you did last summer she
put up a hell of a fight against the
gordon's fisherman
and that whole battling the hordes of
undead bloodsuckers in between cheer
practice thing
yeah that's enough to get her a win in
round three we can shop and hang out and
go to school
and save the world from unspeakable
demons you know i want to do girly stuff
we got a doozy of a contest now can nev
even the score it want a piece
or will someone else emerge with an
outright win we're about to find
out because now it's time for the wild
card round
iconic moments saving all of us mere
mortals from the likes of outer space
creatures
supernatural entities and [ __ ] boys
is a really tough job
and it's impossible to pull off without
creating a mother load of iconic moments
along the way
this is the moment when the supposedly
dead killer comes back to life
for one last scare
not in my movie these four ladies
combined game tape would make the
vaulted nfl films blush
and it kicks off with 40 years worth of
lori versus michael masterpieces
that played out at the legendary soldier
field
home of the bears i'm sorry the whole
nfl thing kind of carried me away
but they were from illinois so it kind
of fits
my favorite moment between these two is
when they see each other through the
glass
over multiple films a version of this
scene has played out in a variety of
ways when a mere door separates good
from evil right from wrong a hardened
survivalist against a masked lunatic
warrior is the only one in these flicks
who stood up to michael and
lived to tell the tale and in halloween
water
sorry halloween h2o she ups the ante by
saving her kid
hey look folks it's josh hartnett and
his girlfriend hey look folks it's
michelle williams
then she refuses to escape with them not
now
not tonight not ever it's time to finish
the game
she locks the gate grabs an axe and says
let's duel
which kind of makes her aaron burr and
mikey is the guy from the 10
bill
let's not overlook more recent history
when laurie gets america's least
favorite power walker just where she
wants
locked up in the basement burning his
way into hell
and although the release of that sequel
halloween kills has been pushed back a
year
i can go ahead and count a scene from
that teaser as iconic
laurie gets a brief moment of relief
followed by the terror of hearing
fire engine sirens coming to put out the
flames i salute you firefighters but
please
let this house burn
[Music]
sometimes vampires can be burned alive
or dead is it
but they don't often fall for the whole
getting the paper in the morning and
forgetting that the sun is out routine
no you usually gotta end their reign
with a stake right through the heart
and buffy earned the moniker a vampire
slayer for
a reason ladies and gentlemen enjoy
very well you eat this late you're gonna
get heartburn
get it heartburn
i'm super sorry i forgot to warn any
vampires to avert their eyes but if it
makes y'all feel any better
you're not the only one sarah michelle
gellar has pounded into dust
now who's the dam's on distress
straight up
[Applause]
in the scooby-doo movies she ain't no
damsel in distress
and as much as anyone else it's daphne
that is the most fearless of the bunch
and in the grudge the paranormal tear is
even more real
that flick might feature one of the most
memorable horror movie shower scenes
not starring jamie lee curtis's mom
geller is such a badass she even plays
her heart out in a losing effort
it's a three-part slugfest that captain
hook has to endure
before sarah is finally failed and i
know what you did last summer
and just for sheer frightfest
entertainment the scream 2 death
that's one for the ages
but if it's scream vengeance she seeks
get sidney prescott's number out of the
school directory
the headshot on stew at the end of the
original is a grade superstar
material not to mention when she mimics
laurie strode and has to take out her
half brother
in scream three by the time he got to
scream four most folks walked in
assuming ghostface was finally going to
get his woman
but no one told that to nev jill her
niece
becomes the latest in the pantheon of
masked woodsboro creeps to meet her
demise
at the hands of sydney he forgot the
first rule of remakes jill
don't [ __ ] with the original it's a
tough call for who has the bestest
mostest iconic moment
so far but what's that
good god that's alan ripley's music okay
maybe it's not actual
notes or chords but sigourney certainly
loves the rhythmic sound
of an airlock she's utilized it to her
advantage in both alien
and aliens in the first adventure she
was so hell-bent on taking care of this
thing that she locks the crew out
that's commitment to the job then aliens
gave us one of the greatest lines in the
history of sci-fi thriller cinema
get away from her you [ __ ] that load
lifter is so
cool and i have yet to see it under the
tree on christmas morning
santa if you're watching i'm gonna keep
asking
oh
what separates sigourney's marquee
character from the pack is her
unselfishness
she embraces the role of being a
motherly savior not just to newt
or briefly an alien but to all of us
earthlings
she is the mom that comforts our globe
by choosing to kill an alien by
sacrificing herself
rather than risk this thing heading to
our world it's a tough call here
as we're looking at decades of movie and
television entertainment
but i'm giving this round and thus the
win to sigourney weaver
not only is she the archetype of what a
tough protagonist looks like
you also want no part of her on the
basketball court get home safe
and take those skills to the rucker
what i admire about all of our
contestants today is their extreme
ability to save our ass
while enduring an intense character arc
their journeys
would make joseph campbell at another
volume to the hero with a thousand faces
through all her seasons of tv greatness
buffy's entire worldview
changed she went from optimus to
pessimist and learned to care about
others so much that at one point it cost
her her life
twice
laurie strode did her best to maintain a
normal life
even though the fear of michael's
imminent return lingered
she was always ready eternally prepared
and when the moments arrived
she came through in the clutch happy
halloween michael
maybe more than anyone else nev campbell
sydney prescott typifies the final girl
concept
and by the end of scream 4 we realize
that there's only one unstoppable force
in that franchise
her and yes kids i think she's coming
back for scream five
i don't know about you but i feel a
whole lot better but my winner today
is sigourney weaver on the strength of
intergalactic martyr
ellen ripley she wasn't born ready to
end it all for our greater good but
thank goodness she got there you gotta
think that even the predators have an
honorary spot in their hall of fame
for miss ripley but this is just one
fella's opinion
and now the pressure is on you dear
viewer
chances are at least one of these ladies
has saved you without you even knowing
it
so thank them by casting your vote in
the comment section below
and defend your choice i read them all
because
i'm not busy saving earth i'm just a fan
watching these movies and shows and
getting inspired to revisit their
amazing cinematic journeys
i think i'll do that tonight turn the
lights off fire up the subwoofer
put some jiffy pop on the stove oh wait
drew is that
is that not a good idea
you